es una respuesta a lo que la ue
considera un intento ilegal de acaparar
tierras y cambiar las fronteras
internacionales el miércoles la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
vonder Legends propuso una nueva serie
de sanciones contra Rusia
exactamente
ni ningún tipo de anexión en Ucrania y
estamos decididos a hacer que el kremlin
pague por esta nueva escalada esto
mantendrá los productos rusos fuera del
mercado europeo y privará a Rusia de
unos ingresos adicionales de 7000
millones de euros
bajo las nuevas restricciones
comerciales ciertas tecnologías de la
Unión Europea que podrían ayudar a la
maquinaria de guerra de Rusia ya no se
exportarán y también habría
prohibiciones adicionales para la
prestación de servicios europeos las
nuevas sanciones también Proponen
incluir en la lista negra a más personas
y entidades rusas además proporcionaría
una base legal para un tope al precio
del petróleo ruso el g7 que incluye
Italia Francia y Alemania ya acordado en
principio imponer un top al precio al
combustible para terceros países esto
significa que los países participantes
tienen gran servicios occidentales como
los seguros a los cargamentos de
petróleo cuyo precio supere el límite en
mayo la unión continental acordó dejar
de importar el llamado oro negro ruso
que llega por mar desde finales de este
año pero a otros países como la India y
China no se les ve la intención de parar
de adquirir el petróleo ruso también
sabemos que algunos países en vías de
desarrollo siguen necesitando algunos
suministros de petróleo ruso pero a
precios bajos este tope del precio del
petróleo ayudará a reducir los ingresos
de Rusia por un lado y mantendrá estable
el mercado Mundial de la energía
europea tardó cuatro semanas en aprobar
su última ronda de sanciones sus líderes
tienen previsto debatir las últimas
propuestas el viernes